if you were stuck in disneyland for
prisoners where you're forced to compete
in games to the death what would you do
i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to be
the death prison in dead man wonderland
this student is about to see everyone he
knows brutally died ganta here is a
small town kid living like any normal
teenager however his life is about to
change forever relaxing with his friends
this school day is going like any other
and that's when he hears a creepy song
from outside the building he turns his
head and notices a strange figure
floating outside the window suddenly it
sends a shock wave through the classroom
killing everyone in sight realizing he's
the only one still alive he looks up and
sees the strange figure holding his best
friend's head in the air with her body
nowhere to be seen this red man closes
in on scared little ganta pushing a
mysterious diamond into ganta's chest
causing him to pass out this is
terrifying that creepy smile makes me
think that red men enjoyed killing all
of our friends and despite all this i
think we could have gotten out of this
situation with some superhuman reflexes
at our disposal now it's not every day
we see some crazed looking demon
floating outside our classroom but in
japan you never know what can happen as
we can see that blast was pretty damn
strong and left everyone dead but if it
were me there might be a slim chance we
could have survived and here's how if i
was one of these students who wasn't
protected by plot armor i would have run
towards the blast lying down against the
walls underneath the exposed windows as
this will be our best bet to making it
out alive there's no time to open the
doors and run like hell so this is
literally our only option the blast
itself was strong but it wasn't strong
enough to take out the actual building
structure itself this makes me suspect
that this situation could be dealt with
something similar to a bomb blast the
first thing we want to avoid is any
flying debris attacking our pretty faces
and particularly me because i am
gorgeous and it will also help subdue
the effects of the shockwave emitted
from the blast the blast also looked
like it had the blast radius of a couple
grenades and knowing that just one
military issued standard m67 grenade has
a kill radius of between 5 and 15 meters
that means there's no way in hell that
over 30 of these kids are making it out
of that classroom in time with an
explosion such as this so rather than
run stay low people ganta wakes up in
the hospital to a terrifying surprise
he's now being charged with the gruesome
murder of all of his classmates and if
that wasn't bad enough somehow there's
video evidence showing the police that
he committed the murders this seals
ganta's fate as the police sent him to
the most deadly prison in all of japan
dead man wonderland a prison theme park
designed for tourists to come watch
prisoners tear each other apart in
horrifying death games but ganta is
about to find out that there's more in
store for him than he could ever imagine
at orientation ganta learns how the
prison works its scary rules and
terrifying punishments this is also
where he meets a strange girl called
shiro who reminds ganta of his dead
classmate the two become friends as she
shows ganta around the prison but this
is a prison and nowhere is safe and so
ganta almost immediately gets himself
into a fight suddenly an explosion comes
from the top of the prison tower a
massive fireball comes falling down and
there's nowhere to run that's when ganta
here activates his special abilities for
the very first time making a gigantic
force field and saving both him and
shiro in the process some time later
ganta here wakes up with no idea of what
just happened the doctor here tells him
of these prison collars they're forced
to wear providing gps data not only that
the caller is constantly seeping poison
into their bodies this means that every
prisoner is on a time limit and if they
don't eat a anti-poison candy every
three days they will die but
unfortunately for ganta he can't find
his candy to save his own life ganta
meets this new guy called yo and he
tells ganta about a dog race show taking
place very soon which is a show where
participants get a free red bean bun and
the winner gets prison credits meaning
that gante can buy himself another
life-saving candy and avoid dying if he
wins with no other options and the only
way to survive is by joining a game that
is looking to savagely kill you ganta
signs up for the money and the tasty red
bean bun we need to address the whole
poison dog collar thing what are we pets
the fact of the matter is is that our
callers deliver poison to us on a
consistent basis and that makes me
believe that it can only be done through
some sort of absorbent patch much like
how a nicotine patch works the fact is
we can't rid the poison out of our
systems if we don't know what poison is
being used so i'd ask around for
starters maybe schmooze a nurse for
example and see if anyone knows anything
more about our collars and i say poison
and not venom as venom can only be
injected via a needle bite or sting due
to its mixture of large and small
molecules which means we have some big
problems but whatever the case we need
to get a move on we don't seem to have
any side effects from poisoning yet like
nausea seizures or trouble breathing but
i wouldn't rely on no damn candy to feel
better sugar-free or not as a constant
prolonged exposure to poison can have
some permanent side effects ganta at the
races gathers with everyone else and
they kick off as they near the first
guillotine challenge in the race
crossing a pair of swinging guillotines
ganta then gets a nasty surprise by
getting cut immediately realizing the
blades are real and that if he isn't
careful he could get chopped in half
right here blood and guts follow as
ganta navigates his way through this
death track people die left and right as
prisoners and viewers scream in terror
and excitement it's a bloodbath except
for shiro who isn't terrified as she and
ganta enter the bungee jump of death as
she pushes ganta off the podium with her
as they fall to their near deaths barely
avoiding being splattered onto the
ground they then move on to the poof
with archery challenge ganta runs over a
bridge as cute little owl archers try
and kill him with arrows but luckily
shiro cleverly manages to help ganta
avoid all of the arrows as they clumsily
make their way through this death track
but not before jumping over the bouncing
balls track right above a sea of liquid
acid body parts fly everywhere as
prisoners continue to get brutally
murdered past the spiky dodgeballs
tumbling bridges and actual guillotines
and flaming fires ganda and shiro
finally make it to the last challenge
the battle royale we're the last
challenger to hold the deadman ball at
the end is to be declared the winner
ganta and shiro put up a good fight as
they managed to escape the falling
panels lots of limber movements and
quick reflexes almost help ganta win the
game but at the last second he has to
choose between winning the game and
saving shiro from certain death and so
he chooses to save shiro ending the dog
race with no winner ok shiro did do most
of the heavy lifting in the race but we
have something that no one else has
shiro herself and this tall glass of
japanese milk here is seemingly
invincible to dying which means we're
going to use her powers of invincibility
to keep us safe now for the first
challenge shiro isn't needed but what we
do need is to slow the hell down since
we don't seem to have a time limit
instead of running recklessly through
the swinging axes which is what everyone
wants i would crawl through the center
of the pathway to reach the other side
as we can see the axes make enough of a
gap for gotha's tiny frame to crawl
through without a problem now he can
avoid getting a nasty cut and rests easy
knowing that he's not going to bleed out
anytime soon for the long bungee rope
where you had to pick between the longer
or shorter rope we need to get a little
more crafty from the look of ganta's
fall he fell for a near two seconds
calculating the speed of gravity times
the two second fault that ganta endured
means that we are roughly 64 feet up in
the air at least three times the height
of a survivable drop this means we would
need some way to break our fall since
shiro doesn't care about her life i'd be
the best worst scumbag and i would use
her to our advantage you're welcome i'd
simply steal shiro's cord and attach it
to my harness along with the second cord
and then jump this way as i fall the
shorter rope aka the safer rope due to
its length would be the first rope to
tighten up breaking my fall just before
hitting the ground landing safely with
the final boss there's no way we can win
head on and this guy doesn't seem that
smart so i would use his ego against him
to make him super overly confident and
then force his hand by making him super
mad and charge at us like a matador to a
bull before dodging his charge making
him fall to his death later at his
celganta without any candy sits sadly as
he counts the hours until poison kills
him as without any prison candy he is
surely going to die fortunately his new
prison friend from earlier yo enters and
offers him a new candy that he has this
cheers ganta up and the two boys head
out to get some ice cream to celebrate
however their time to celebrate is
short-lived as gantu sees the terrifying
red man who smiles wide as he readies to
kill more people and he blasts everyone
in the courtyard this angers god to who
without realizing uses his new powers
against red men chasing him away in the
process and causing gata to suddenly
pass out ganta later wakes up and
finally realizes that he has become the
monster he hoped to kill finally
realizing his true powers he also begins
to hear about rumors of a mysterious
place hidden within the prison called
g-block where the terrifying red man may
be located wasting no time ganta sets
out to find g block by himself and on
the way runs into shiro who happens to
know where g block is and sets out to
show him the way they also run into yo
on the way there as well but the party
stops when they come face to face with a
murderous security robot who begins to
chase them down to kill them missiles
start flying as the gang finally reaches
g-block where shiro is almost killed by
the security robot but is saved by cool
guy in shock ganta tries to fight this
mysterious cool guy who ganta thinks is
the red man who killed his classmates
however cool guy doesn't know just what
the hell ganta is talking about and
tells him that there are hundreds of
super powered people within g block with
similar powers to him and ganta we also
finally learned that ganta's powers
require his blood to work and that he
needs to bleed first before being able
to activate his powers their
conversation is cut short as some prison
guards find them and tuck them into bed
so to speak hold on shiro here seemingly
knows everything about this place and
has the luck of a black cat with four
leaf clovers so we need to start
thinking of her as the muscle around
here as we've seen her strength
durability and agility in action
especially at those death games and
since she hasn't been killed by her own
stupidity yet and until we figure out
our powers better i would play her like
a fiddle and charm my way to her pretty
little heart and order her to dismantle
those security robots right after yo's
sticky fingers took it out earlier and
speaking of dying cool guy here while
seemingly looking like a douche is our
best bet in staying alive and figuring
out more information about this place
and as much as i'd like to slice his
carotid arteries with a surgeon's
scalpel hannibal style we need to play
it cool and act as weak and feeble as
possible because i'm a damsel in
distress cool guy is the only one who we
know in g-block and someone who looks
like he knows how to use his powers
which is why we need to befriend him and
do our best not to piss him off until we
figure out our powers more in fact maybe
we could learn a thing or two from him i
to charm the skinny jeans right out of
him and get him over to our side asap
maybe even having him look into our
poison callers more he's a certified
super villain which means he'll know
others like him and maybe even redman so
let's use him to our advantage ganta
wakes up to find himself being trapped
and examined by the promoter of the
prison the same guy who also acted as
our fake lawyer planting false evidence
against ganta including that fake video
and who got ganta sent to prison this is
where we learned that this promoter uses
this prison as a place to experiment on
people surgically implanting the seed of
sin into their body and eventually
turning them into dead men who then
compete in superhero-like death games
the next day ganta is forced to fight
against cool guy in a death match but
struggles to beat him due to blood loss
we find out that this means ganta can't
shoot his blood too much as just like
any normal person too much blood loss
can lead to anemia and a loss of
function which sucks for ganta because
cool guy's powers are simply terrifying
but luckily ganta manages to pull a fast
one on cool guy and defeats him barely
winning the match ganta was pretty
stupid to go in as unprepared as he did
we know blood is the main driving force
behind all of this so we should start
optimizing our blood glucose levels like
actual athletes and to make sure that we
can function optimally throughout the
match as we know glucose is a type of
sugar that our body gets from foods and
uses for energy and low blood sugar
levels can cause a variety of problems
like weakness lightheadedness and
dizziness this is why i would try to
increase our blood sugar levels before a
death match making sure our body has a
steady state of energy throughout
without getting depleted just like a
heavy duty training session at the gym
before a death match i would fuel up
with a meal made up of fast acting
carbohydrates around 15 to 30 grams
which can come from fruit juice white
rice or even some kid's cereal fast
acting carbs will help us raise our
blood sugar levels the fastest keeping
our levels elevated during our death
match also why is ganta shooting his
blood you are literally giving away your
power if ganda is maybe 150 pounds and
shooting a couple of shots of his
gaunted gun makes him dizzy this means
that he's losing between 15 to 30
percent of his body's total blood
meaning every time ganta fires his ganta
gun he wastes 10 ounces of his precious
blood that's a lot he should really try
changing to a blood sword or some blood
boxing gloves or something ganta wakes
up later and eats his candy as he hears
a girl scream for her dear life being
the oh so freaking noble one ganta
rushes to go save her and we find out
that this girl is another dead man with
powers who is a little bit crazy but
turns out ganta loves crazy and he
immediately takes a liking to this crazy
girl as she convinces him to run away
with her and of course love struganta
falls for it and leads her out into the
hallway as crazy girl accidentally
injures ganta's leg just as they run
into some prison guards and as fate
would have it these two are to face each
other in a death match the next day they
arrive in the grand cage but as it turns
out crazy girl here is a complete
psychopath she set ganta up by injuring
his leg the day before meaning his
chances of beating her are slim to none
ganta doesn't have time to react however
as yo shows up and reveals that he's the
brother of the crazy girl in the midst
of all of the twists and turns and crazy
girl even managing to attack her own
brother ganta finally defeats her and
puts an end to it all after the match he
makes peace with crazy girl and bumps
into cool guy who tells him that he
needs to learn more attack moves than
just using his ganta gun later on ganta
bumps into white-haired girl who tells
him that she's part of a group of dead
men that are planning to escape and that
they want ganta to join them at their
bar headquarters we also meet the leader
of this group scarfy and that's when
dead man killer rock star drops by along
with a bean up yo and takes out
everybody with his special guitar gun
suddenly shiro appears out of nowhere
and breaks rockstar's gun chasing him
away ganta is then introduced to the
entire resistance gang of dead men all
of whom plan to escape they have a bar
in prison like that is awesome but why
didn't they put some type of little
security system at the very least right
outside of their bar i mean if this is
your base of operations i would have at
least had some security guys outside
when discussing plans and from the looks
of things rockstar's eyes are not
shielded which means we could try to
blind him temporarily at least as with
any type of chemical like alcohol in the
eye this can cause corrosive effects to
occur this means if we use any 20 proof
or more alcohol like vodka this could
cause corneal abrasions and eye scarring
which can result in loss of vision and
even blindness in some cases so
basically i would make a run to the bar
find some strong vodka and when fling it
all over rockstar's face giving us
enough of a head start to either jump
him tackle him or make ourselves bleed
to use our dead man powers against him
before he has the chance to use that
rifle again or if anyone had a lighter
we could have simply done it like the
finish did with their invention way back
and throw some molotov cocktails at him
meeting all the members ganta visits the
brains behind the whole operation mr
smart guy he reveals toganta that the
plan is to escape during the prison's
inspection week when the human rights
authorities will be conducting a visit
into the prison this is a week when the
prison will be forced to act all nice
and sweet and won't be doing any death
game shows this makes it the perfect
time to escape that is if they can first
take out that special group of prison
guards known as the undertakers these
guys are the worst of the worst of the
prison guards who specialize in killing
dead men ganta then informs the group
that his powers didn't work against
rockstar earlier which no one believes
as smart guy shows them footage showing
rockstar clearly dodging ganta's blood
bullet but they don't realize that this
was their biggest mistake and one that
will cost them everything with no one
believing him ganda angrily storms out
and runs into cool guy where he learns
more about the dead men group and their
leader scarfy we also find out more
about scarfy's tragic past and the
grudge to kill rockstar who murdered his
pregnant wife years earlier feeling bad
ganda decides to join in on the group
now the breakout plan is on ok this
seems sweet and all but trusting the
leadership of a guy with a huge chip on
his shoulder and something to prove is a
huge red flag scarves intentions may be
good but like any good leader i can't
rely on him to ensure that he makes the
right decisions based on logic if this
is personal for him which it is he may
slip up and make moves out of emotion
certainly endangering us even further
and risking the whole plan in the
process to ensure the integrity of this
plan we ought to make sure someone else
is in charge with way less invested
feelings in this situation as their
judgment is a lot less likely to get
clouded as scarfies is this is going to
cost them more than they realize the
group goes back over the plan with the
intent to show the world what dead man
wonderland really is the plan is to
sneak out a data chip containing a bunch
of illegal things that the prison has
done the group decides to split into two
groups during the alarms to confuse the
guards with one group going to take over
the control room and gauntus group
heading towards the service elevators
that lead to the exit of the prison
ganta's group will also be carrying the
data chip with them the group then sets
out alarm bells go off as they run into
another one of those pesky security
robots who nearly takes out the bridge
and savagely kills another dead man
forcing white-haired girl to sacrifice
herself in the process the group finally
reaches the elevator and after waiting
for what seems like forever the
elevators finally open up the gang
rushes up only to meet rockstar and his
undertaker army turns out this was a
trap all along cornered and scared the
group tries to fight back but fails as
their dead man powers don't seem to work
against the undertaker's suit which
means ganta was right earlier about
rockstar it's a slaughterhouse as dead
men get their heads chopped off and
blood spills everywhere resulting in
almost every single dead man dying
rockstar then leaves the last few alive
as he has bigger plans to add insult to
injury shiro finally shows up randomly
and steals the data chip from ganta and
destroys it in the process now their
only piece of evidence against dead man
wonderland is gone leaving the defeated
dead man survivors to retreat back to
the bar well that's just great not only
did shiro destroy our only evidence but
somebody clearly betrayed us and this
group of capable dead men did everything
wrong they could have avoided the
security robot entirely if they sealed
off the door entrance to the bridge
after they went through it in fact i
would have sealed off every room as we
made our exit we're not coming back so
there was no reason not to destroy at
least parts of our escape route as we
cleared every room this could have
prevented any robots and guards from
following us or at least slowed them
down and kept everyone alive and
speaking of entrances their only escape
plan was through one elevator and one
exit which by itself is way too risky
and loud which is to not say a loud and
proud prison escape is invalid as there
are many examples of famous loud prison
escapes like the one done by the famous
texas seven who during a prison escape
took 16 prisoners hostage and escaped a
maximum security prison however in this
case i think it would have been better
to be more subtle about it like ronaldo
silva a famous man who once attempted to
escape a brazilian prison by dressing up
as his wife it's a good pastime you
should try it with that just being said
i'm not saying we should dress up as our
wives but i think we would have had an
easier time of getting through the
prison by dressing up as the prison
security personnel hell i would have
seen if there was any way we could have
stolen an undertaker uniform as that
would have allowed us to hide our faces
and would have made for a much quieter
and easier escape and speaking of which
trying to sneak out over 15 dead men was
too risky if their plan was to reveal to
the world the horrors surrounding this
prison then i would have brought only
one or two dead men with me to escape
along with the data chip it's harsh i
know but it was unreasonable to expect
everyone to make it out of a high
security prison without some casualties
or problems or we could have even given
the data chip to the government
officials who were already within the
prison for inspection week like ganta
you could have done this prison escape
so much better the group sits defeated
in the bar just as white-haired girl
shows up from the dead and looks like
all is not over just yet as she hasn't
given up and has another plan up her
non-existent sleeve suddenly mr smart
guy shows up and we find out that he was
working with rockstar editing the fake
video of ganta missing his shot planting
a bomb at the data chip meant to kill
all the dead men and betray scarfy who
is now missing suddenly more undertakers
show up to kill all the dead men but
luckily cool guy springs up and tries to
cut the undertaker's suits but fails as
smart guy reveals to us that the
undertaker suits are made of oxidizing
accelerators that conduct an ultra high
pressure of 20 pascal's worth of
shielding meaning the undertakers are
able to disable any dead man powers but
cool guy just like his abs won't quit
and creates a new trick up his sexy
sleeve using a never before seen special
attack a super sonic blade cutting
through the undertaker suits and weapons
at the speed of sound let's take a look
at the undertaker suits really quick
these guys are absolute beasts but we
need to figure out how their armor works
really fast basically one mega pascal is
equal to about 145 pounds of pressure
per square inch meaning that the
undertaker suits and weapons have around
2 900 pounds of pressure shielding per
square inch this type of shielding is
also achieved by what is known as a worm
eater a type of small device that is
capable of stopping the powers of dead
men by turning their solid attacks into
ordinary liquid this is how their armor
works by using his dead man powers at
the speed of sound cool guy was able to
cut through the undertaker's suits
without interference from the worm eater
technology which means this is the way
that we beat them this makes me wonder
how come no one has ever bothered to
talk to cool guy before he's clearly one
of the strongest dead men here and
figured out how to beat the undertakers
the least we could have done is gone his
feedback on this plan before starting it
also asking cool guy to train them to
beat the undertakers is not a bad idea
i'm just saying they should have
involved him in the plan in some way
ideally even convincing him to go along
with them and of course a prisoner in a
prison betrayed us shocker and as a
leader scarfy should have double checked
the plan and he should have checked if
the data chip had anything in it or not
despite how nice everyone is we are in a
prison after all and they are prisoners
and i doubt everyone here is as innocent
and pure like ganta after cool guy
defeats the undertakers he declines the
offer from ganta's group to escape
thinking he belongs in prison like the
savage stud that he is however he does
agree to help train ganta for what's to
come cool guy helps him upgrade his
ganta gun ability to get it to shoot
faster than the speed of sound which
ganta soon learns and just in the nick
of time too as ganta is about to be
tested to his absolute limit in just a
few moments suddenly he sees on tv that
white-haired girl and shiro have been
kidnapped by rockstar and are being held
hostage at the undertaker's headquarters
wasting no time ganta sets off to find
their base eventually reaching it
however he now faces a new problem as
gata suddenly becomes dizzy and is
already at his limit looks like somebody
has been forgetting to eat his candy
dizzy and only half awake ganta barely
manages to take out most of the
undertakers as rockstar reveals a
destroyed and soulless scarfy now turned
evil and vengeful he's alive but might
as well be dead and he now claims life
means nothing and nothing matters scarfy
who's clearly lost his mind at this
point tries to beat up shiro as a
weakened ganta protects her and gets
himself and white-haired girl to talk
some sense into him this seems to work
however he gets shot in the chest by
rockstar and this causes gata to freak
out as he then pulls out his new uber
cool superhero move and uses his famous
and newly improved gontagon to shoot and
kill rockstar firing his blood gun at
supersonic speed blowing more than a
whole couple of holes into rockstar for
the very last time alright we did it but
ganta yet again failed to plan ahead and
as a result got his teammate scarfy
killed in the process for starters ganta
shouldn't have given all of his candy to
cool guy that was unbelievably stupid i
mean he could have kept one and we could
have at least stopped by the kitchen or
even a damn vending machine on the way
to the undertaker's headquarters as for
getting to take our candy aside ganta
should have also eaten before his next
fight as we already talked about this
remember the golden rule the better the
blood sugar we got the better the
butcher we are you know what i'm pissed
at everyone guys we could have at least
tried asking for cool guy to help us
like i said earlier or even yo's batshit
crazy sister who we ran into right
before we got into the undertaker's
headquarters and speaking of which this
was the perfect opportunity for ganta at
his pals to grab weapons from the
undertakers as they took some of them
out and this way we could have saved up
some of our powers for the main bad guy
rockstar himself and ganta did
everything right with rockstar somehow
pulling a finishing move out of nowhere
but what i would have done is violently
push shiro into rockstar right as i took
out my ganta gun using her body as a
shield of meat so to speak preventing
rockstar from getting me with his guitar
gun before blasting both shiro and
rockstar away killing both of them in
the process cold heartless and totally
not necessary i love it with rockstar
dead white haired girl and ganta gather
around scarfy as he gives ganta his
candy before dying shiro asks him if he
plans to escape with white-haired girl
and the rest of the dead man bugatta
tells her that he can't leave her a
friend behind the rest of the dead men
escape as ganta and shiro sit on top of
the prison building looking out onto the
skyline as shiro sings a familiar song
shocked ganta realizes that it's the
same creepy modi that he first heard at
school right before his classmates were
brutally murdered but he lets his
suspicion slide showing us just how
whipped ganta really is and if you don't
want to be wrapped around shiro's
fingers like a tasty ring pop don't
forget to like and subscribe comment
down below and check out how to be
playlist